before you have corrupt judges we don't  have corrupt judges we have a totally  corrupt judiciary which works like a  corporation and which works like  for-profit industry and we are breaking  it down starting from this reform that  will pass info let me ask you about some  of the allegations that have come your  way on August the 12th a opposition  leader losing Basha accused you of  publicly dealing with organized crime he  said your government is deeply connected  to crime you're not saying anything  about these accusations we live in a  civilization that this long time as has  a principle it's up to the user to prove  the accusation and not to be accused to  prove that he is not guilty if I'd be  answering all the time to the  allegations I would not have time to do  anything else even to eat